a snowplow is actually the big blade on
a snow clearing vehicle not the vehicle
itself the first snow plows were
wedge-shaped wooden blades drawn by
horses as cars replaced horses these
gave way to metal plows mounted to the
front of trucks and other large machines
a snow plow is a blade made of either
stainless steel which is rust proof or
carbon steel which they code in plastic
based powder paint to prevent rust to
begin making the blade they take a sheet
of metal about 1/10 of an inch thick and
insert it in a press the press punches
out holes for the bolts which attach the
blade to the mounting structure next
they feed the sheet through a rolling
press the rollers apply 35 to 40 tons of
pressure perving the sheet to the
required shape workers check that the
front radius and top radius of the curve
meet the technical specifications next
using a machine called a press break
they bend over the top of the sheet
[Music]
this Venn will sit on the top bar of the
mounting structure the mounting
structure is made of several parts cut
from giant plates of carbon steel a
[Music]
computer guides the cutting machine
which uses electrode generated flames
their intense focused heat slices
through the steel literally by melting
it the steel is too hot to handle when
the plasma cutting is done so workers
lift off the parts with magnets then
they Bend key load-bearing parts in a
press break to increase the structural
strength they position the parts for one
section of the structure in an assembly
fixture and weld them together in a
different assembly fixture they position
the parts for another section of the
structure a robot welds those together
[Music]
back at the first assembly they use pins
to attach a spring-loaded component
called a trip edge it protects the
vehicle from damage by absorbing the
shock through the springs rather than
through the vehicle frame should the
plow hit an obstacle on the road after
welding the two sections together
workers send the structure to the powder
coating area their workers spray at
first with powder primer then with
powder paint each coat is baked to
activate the plastic base which produces
an ultra durable shell over the metal
once the structure cools workers install
the springs for the trip edge then they
attach the base of the structure called
the cutting edge it's made of a harder
type of steel because it scrapes the
ground
the structure is now finished and ready
to receive the blade this one's getting
a stainless steel blade the bent top
fits over the structures top bar the
bottom into a slot below workers secure
the blade with bolts then finish off the
plow with the decal for this model they
make two plows like this mirror images
of each other they go side by side
connected in the middle by a hinge to
form a v-shape snow plow straight plows
have a single blade attached to a
different type of structure all the
parts except stainless steel blades are
powder painted and baked the V plow
articulates the driver can adjust the
width of the V to direct the snow
another model combines a straight blade
with hinged blades for clearing snow in
large areas such as parking lots when it
comes to these types of machines there's
clearly no business like snow business
[Music]